how's it going breath my spirit back you
excited you better be Sadie this is a
season finale of the wolf among us hell
yeah baby
episode 5 right well of a long way you
must be tired oh yeah we chose to smoke
the cigarette mm-hmm you kind of have
like girlish features in a bad ass phase
it's kind of perplexing correct recently
he's so [ __ ] ugly could say to say
about him George a drink something to
eat Vivian makes it very nice it's
Lobster all right you sold me all names
getting well
Gramercy me take a seat we're not gonna
stand the situation here we are not
friends you're in no position to offer
me anything
damn straight contrary sheriff and I
don't wish to contradict you here but
your initiative and mine have been
friendly for a long while now ever since
I came aboard these shores
you know Fabletown has been very
accommodating of my humble ventures
never said a bad word and that
relationships work till these ends that
was Crane who let you do whatever you
wanted I'm
not crane oh yeah baby no you're not
I'm way more handsome why did you're
doing he's gonna mr. Wolfe is our guest
and I have every intention of
cooperating yes ginger spots I don't
trust em silver sit down Jersey so many
ginger spots well Sheriff turns me on
for the sake of transparency why don't
you tell us why you're here everyone's
nerves I think you know why I'm here
you killed those women women faith and
Lily the girls who worked at the pudding
and pie I know I assume by your
confidence in accusing me you must have
some proof of this yes
our [ __ ] witness perhaps oh god it's a
terrible answer but I have to I'm sorry
I wish you had me dead to rights
I really do for your own sake but no I
didn't kill anyone those women I don't
release telling you that the killings
were perpetrated by an employee of mine
it's a very unfortunate bit of business
but I promise you that the matter will
be dealt with internally I just want to
settle the issue for you and to assure
you that it's over with you really don't
need to worry yourself further I already
know who did it
forgive me sheriff for doubting your
acumen but oh [ __ ] he's gonna ask know
every habits I think it was Georgie
it was Georgie all right if you don't
mind near that [ __ ] yeah I killed him
so what [ __ ] [ __ ]
I should have [ __ ] known look the
fact is George here misinterpreted one
of my instruction misinterpret and I
want to make things right so let's work
something out what's there to work out
I'm protected our night your protection
has limits and I think you far exceeded
yours but you couldn't murder someone in
cold blood like that killing me for it
you will be silent while we discuss what
to do with you this is right bollocks
this you're just gonna let him do this
oh they [ __ ] out can we discuss terms
thank don't you know Georgie consider it
a gift
ensuring our continued cooperation
what the hell take this [ __ ] take all
of them I think if I make him talk they
might start fighting alright let's talk
you can't just hand me over
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] you said you'd
cover for us for minor infractions not
much just go at him Georgie you're gonna
sink us all what's wrong with you people
you're really gonna sell him out just
like that God give a [ __ ] if I'm the one
working sheriff but I think it's best if
you leave now there's no way I'm going
with him you kidding me things are about
to get unpleasant and I would rather you
weren't here to watch oh he's gonna go
join now or at the bottom of the lake
for all I give a [ __ ] but he's not
taking me anywhere is he gonna transform
I'll roll over on the lot of you before
I let that [ __ ] happen what are you
saying yeah what the [ __ ] you're gonna
make sure we all go down the [ __ ]
with you I told you I'm not going
anywhere else could have gone so well
really
uh-oh what's gonna happen to choose I've
never been a good mediator why negotiate
when you can just decide oh [ __ ] he's
coming out oh god Blair Mary I don't
like that [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
did I miss anything good well look at
you all fixed up nice [ __ ] Oh got it
they're all there
alright this will be a battle for [ __ ]
sake
god damn I can't take them oh yes oh
damn where are they going
oh come on oh oh my god come on get it
baby
Oh mamacita mine you ugly piece of [ __ ]
come on go
it's Maggie damn
that's how it's done
maybe [ __ ] cuz that's a poop Oh
I
going somewhere
no oh that's the matter
what's going on here what am i doing
is that my health bar I think that's my
health bar or something out alone Jesus
don't [ __ ] this up heads you can do this
come on bro chat shows up because Yolo
up because I'm a gorilla I mean whatever
I am I don't know that was awesome
now white not [ __ ] alright
what's in there nope there they all
right
badge a cake this is awesome so freakin
cool
it's a lot of [ __ ] people in this
town
uh-oh what's that the wrong way yeah I
got it [ __ ] what do you think I know I
picked the wrong car son of a [ __ ]
alright what are you gonna do you're
coming with me ma'am god no
wiggle wiggle wiggle
and [ __ ] me that's [ __ ] it
I can't be 800 you wanna pee on it are
you sure do it
Oh
Oh Oh I didn't click anything oh they
get away really we follow them all this
way to follow them to the most obvious
spot ever
are you serious nice pics
I'm the puddin in the pack let's examine
the car really quick all that was fun
let's not do that again
so obviously George he just [ __ ]
ratted him out him out the crook man
he's I don't think he's responsible at
all I need a minute okay
I've listened to them really quick
[ __ ] L hope it be I hope to come to
senses crooked man's the one you want
but of course you're too much of an
idiot to see that or maybe you just like
me too much to let me go please Sheriff
haven't you done enough look at him he's
dying you can't seriously want to
protect this guy you know what he did
I'm not going anywhere the [ __ ] it isn't
his fault he's a murderer faith in Lilly
he's the reason they're dead look I know
he made a few mistakes we all have loss
we made sure they couldn't talk with
those damn ribbons and then he killed
them you're wearing one yourself doesn't
that bother you even a little knowing
that man Marta horse it does so so my
[ __ ] fault then are you hungry
you gonna throw this [ __ ] wolf too
you know I did have a goddamn choice
what the [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] blame me
for that look sometimes you just have to
do what you're told then it comes back
to bite you in the ass because some good
for nothing crooked busted decide you're
not worth [ __ ] anymore
why'd you do it then huh it's not your
fault then what the [ __ ] happened look
faith on the others tried to pull a run
on us and as you can imagine the crooked
man wasn't too thrilled but of course
the big boss didn't want to get his
[ __ ] hands dirty so he told me to
take care of it you think I don't know
what that means
either I do what he says or I'm the one
getting dealt with so I [ __ ] killed
him and I'd do it again cuz it's not my
fault the crooked man gave the order he
told me to kill them and any [ __ ]
sold me out you're still the one who
pulled the trigger nobody held your hand
and made you go through with it fine
believe what you want
I can tell you've made up your mind
doesn't matter if it's [ __ ] true or
not the [ __ ] is he talking about go
ahead and kill me then Michael bring
back within your faith it won't free
your friend Nerissa and I'm just the
suck take in the fall for the old thing
he must be so easy being you just come
in here and blame me for all this [ __ ]
jobs don't rush I'm a bad guy it's all
his [ __ ] fault my walls are supposed
to do you don't know what it's like Big
B how could you know at the end of the
day you're just like him coming here
talking about options like it was that
simple stop complaining and take
responsibility for what you did
you murdered faith in Lilly you put
those [ __ ] ribbons around their necks
you had the power to let him go but you
chose not to you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
if I freed them meds would a full life
what would you have me do killer Rudy
don't it was there more Vivian so you
tell me if free Lilly meant she had to
die you still think I had a [ __ ]
choice he do he told you you don't know
the [ __ ] about anything wait no is she
involved in all this yes the original
right the girl with the ribbon I'm sure
you've heard the stories couldn't take
it off couldn't talk about it you used a
little purple ribbon to make more of
them to keep our girls quiet to ensure
absolute discretion you promised you
wouldn't all that magic is connected to
this little thing you remove us spells
broken they're all free but you know
what happens to the same thing that
happened to faith so don't you come in
here and tell me I [ __ ] up what the
hell Georgie we were supposed to look
out for each other I trusted you you
can't [ __ ] blame me you owe no
innocent here either
I know that but did it have to be like
this wait
were your ribbons you're in on this it's
kind of obvious though I thought you
cared about I do of course I do you have
to understand nobody was supposed to die
when we built this place it was just a
stupid idea
a gimmick discretion is our guarantee
that's how it started anyway this was
supposed to be our place we were gonna
be in charge for once and nobody would
try to control us or use us that was the
point and the crooked man showed up and
everything just turned to [ __ ] so no no
I know I couldn't just if you'll still
think it's a [ __ ] simple then you do
it go ahead
killer then what are you doing break the
spell save the [ __ ] down Jesus I told
you sometimes only options a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is supposed to do then I'm not
playing this game Georgie I won't kill
her don't talk about me like I'm not
even here please you think this is hard
for you my life is such a [ __ ] burden
on your conscience don't I get a say
it's my life like it was either of yours
to give up in the first place
I wasn't really shut up you don't get a
choice if you're involved in this I know
what I've done
wait I'm sick of everyone thinking that
they can just do what they want with my
life I thought it would be different
here but it's all the [ __ ] Vivian I
didn't mean do you think I wanted to be
this person what I did to faith and Lily
all of them every day I have to look
Gwen and Hans in the eye and pretend I
don't care I have to
yet what I've done to them but I took
away from them
I look at Nerissa and I hate myself
Vivian I can't pretend anymore what are
you doing he's gonna do oh god what the
[ __ ]
why'd you have to do that Vivian Vivian
[ __ ] damn it damn everything is so far I
didn't [ __ ] mean it I was just oh oh
that's that's a sad man
get up get up don't think so baby and
you just take it back you're gonna die
here I think we both know all that just
to make sure you'll give the crooked man
the same treatment when you find him
really [ __ ] him up for me all right for
both of us you know the Buster deserves
it he's gonna ours Oh worry
good old foundry by the river all right
Shepherd metal works
we'll be there [ __ ] us all you want
to finish me off now or do you plan to
kick me around a little first rip my
limbs off one by one that's what you
want to do right well whatever it is
just get it over with that's not who I
am sure it's not
no more games all right we both know how
this ends
just make it quick I know what I did
let's not draw this out
what you're just gonna leave me here I
can't do it Georgie I can't take another
life you're selfish busted [ __ ] you
piece of [ __ ]
I figured you'd think about what he'd
done in a little bit you know plus I
don't want him to kill more people it's
not that I wanted him to suffer is is it
think of us for the best you know what
I'm saying
[ __ ] music girl this is awesome so
far the pootie and the pie the buckling
in the pie it's my favorite la backlinks
Shepherd's mill work why would they go
there is that their main quarters or
some chat
gets running it doesn't do every time
his limp is that there's yeah it is son
of a [ __ ] I'm glad we got after Georgie
first though he's here all right well we
saw him driving it didn't make pretty
shall we wait all right let's go in oh
look it's your breath shouldn't you just
be little bent yep and that's how it
there it's like the Hulk except he's a
wolf
then it's Harry I don't think the Hulk
is Harry but his pants and clothes stays
intact somehow I don't know how he does
that maybe yeah has like a you know
covering in his butt or some [ __ ] so
this is where they've been sending these
oh yeah the butcher thing whatever
bastards they should know I'm coming
right
considering that lit up this is gonna be
an epic finale because this is an epic
finale place Oh God not that [ __ ]
that's me all right [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill her I'll definitely kill
her
you used to be something
if you all these pictures and they
didn't even tag me
it's in here
I might do it I don't like this price I
don't know what's gonna happen other
making the silver bullets hearing oh
Jesus how the [ __ ] did she do that I had
to take care of some things first
ah pygmy I see you made it here in one
piece
they do apologize but I have some
business to attend to
I leave you in the capable hands of my
associate come find me when you're
finished here don't worry get out of my
way now don't make this worse he doesn't
want to play this way
Oh [ __ ] sake what a man stealing
punches while my back is turned
didn't your mother ever teach you to
fight [ __ ] hey Becky hey what how did
you do that son of a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that chef super okay
she's down here for shizzle I know I had
a place ghost Rizal
I don't think he's gonna end well for
her I don't know what that was I'm so
sorry okay we're going through here for
some reason
uh oh [ __ ] Oh Jason oh my beautiful face
[ __ ] scared me cry Trey she gives a
lot of craic inside her Mane all right
I'll be ready this I'm ready this time
there we go
locking all those weird-ass attacks
come out and face me oh god she's ugly
hi pretty
Oh vodka oh right the hell but spit the
glass
okay you creepy a [ __ ] man okay
oh of course it's a mirror it's a
memories oh we got a dine here brace Oh
out oh it's on
I looked up Volvo's and even though I'm
more hair this is her final form - oh
nice nice and scary you got there oh
that's longer Oh what
are you [ __ ] my supposed to attack
all right that's one nuts find him
oh she's fingering me
yeah
not yet Oh God
am I gonna do my my charge overcharge
overcharge Oh
whoa that's the big bad wolf in today
damn oh that's a big one
Oh God
oh [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] awesome
how the hell are we gonna get her though
oh there's more of them this is like
that matrix scene I'm a charge and my
legs hurt don't tell me how's a good
Zillow laser please be a good deal oh my
god it's a wind blazer I'm just gonna go
back now he's huffing and puffing it's
super effective oh my god it's so
awesome it's one [ __ ] left oh oh oh god
no don't don't don't be doing that
oh no don't stop my eye
Oh Ellie Everett edges tastes like
chicken bloody chicken
alright press I'm really sorry but I got
an India episode a hope you enjoy
watching tomorrow's gonna be the last
episode so it should be pretty awesome I
hope you were so excited go ahead and
leave a like if you are and I'll see you
tomorrow bro flashed but yet